les 4 mai quatre personnes qui vont dire
vos quatre vérités alors n'allez pas
savoir de qui il s'agit de qui vont
parler on va en accueillir une 1re c'est
parti premières personnes à bord et bat
très bien merci alors on va démarrer
elle attend votre avis quelle
chroniqueur il n'aime pas dire il est
mort jeune fils maxime riehl maji maji
lille a les yeux et vous vous pensez
mathieu maintenant avec eux il veut
d'abord on attend gilles c'est ma raison
matthieu delormeau les dans la classe
mini ça va tu es le plus petit mais il
échoue la jalousie je vois ce cas c'est
alors tu t'appelles jonathan jonathan
mon chéri tu viens de fontenay vendée
j'aime bien ton style mais alors là
vraiment je te fais un bisou on dirait
le fils de manu payet mois alors tu
n'aimes pas mature non pas du tout
nonoban on va à travers l'écran il quand
même il dégage un côté légèrement
méprisant part aux gants
oui on voit à travers la télé quand même
été assez méprisant envers eux mêmes les
nouveaux arrivants c'est quand même
assez dommage quand on sait ce pourquoi
tu as quitté provisoirement tpm paix je
trouve que c'est pas tellement légitime
moi je te fuis comme ça et moi là moi à
mon sens aussi je trouve que
tu n'as pas tellement grand chose à
faire autour de la table je pense qu
autour de la table il n'y a que des
professionnels des médias
tu ne te sens pas de trop
[Applaudissements]
les gars ce ne sont pas ce sont des gens
qui disent la dette sont des vérités qui
disent la vérité
dominateur de tpl est pas terminée oui
mais il faut quand même remettre dans
son contexte que tu es plus connu sous
le nom de khadr pour avoir montré tard
et que pour que pour de leurs mots pour
tes analyses médias donc je voulais
juste savoir ça avec toi alors déjà je
suis pas chargé nathan merci de ta
question de la table parce que pour mes
analyses médias en effet mais parce que
cyril avait besoin aussi de personnes
connues notamment de différents
continents et de stars il ya des gens de
médias comme isabelle et il ya aussi des
célébrités vont accueillir d'accord
après pour le reste pour le côté aussi
arrogant méprisant et tout ça c'est très
souvent du second degré jonathan mais le
second degré est une chose qui est livré
avec l'intelligence ce que je voulais
juste a ajouté c'est grâce aux quatre
pierres de jean luc lemoine on l'a
appris du coup que tu ne saluaient
jamais les équipes techniques ou très
peu n'oublie pas que sans elle tu ne
serais pas dans la lumière mon fils pour
finir et après je passe là le micro avec
camarades
tune insiste grâce à jean luc r j'ai
appris je ne saurais rien par hasard que
tu n'assistait pas aux répétitions
répète révision va tu n'en as pas besoin
c'est vrai puisque de toute manière on
te demande uniquement d'imiter johnny
donc au pire des cas
en tout cas c'est l'avis de john
[Applaudissements]
attentats il faut juste face à patrick
sûrs de leur bon alors moi je veux juste
te dire un truc première télé j'ai déjà
un prime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]